so what's up it's all a mess okay I did
and what didn't you like well
considering that it started yesterday
and I'm just now getting home I'm gonna
go with it's too long for starters
starting to think you have an attention
span problem I'm sorry if my attention
span can only tolerate 17 Hugh Jackman
songs before it gives up it could have
been a lot longer they didn't even shoot
the whole quit ahead longer it's not a
defense against the criticism of it was
too long okay
so what else stimuli besides the learn
about the speak singing speak singing
you know they they don't say any lines
of dialogue
everything is so when they're speaking
even if they're only saying oh if the
music was really stupid and it made me
really angry and I wanted to punch them
in the eye you are a good songwriter
they turn every line of dialogue into a
song this forked don't musicals do
that's what I need some milk my cereal
strong could you pass don't have any
cereal what else did in your life all
right well it's Russell Crowe doing in
this movie well why does he sing like s
to poop oh come on he's not that that's
terrible
another problem not enough sex this
movie has a sex scene and Hathaway
right is it he'll go to Anne Hathaway
movies for two reasons to see her naked
that's not movies I need those fool very
mature when I go
I don't even know why I bother talking
to you about movies because movies are
you done movies so came to know listen
when we talk about some of them what
about the riot in the street but it's
just so small what do you need small
well the movie makes you feel like it's
some sort of historical trigger event
it's just a bunch of teenagers who had
too much beer hiding out behind some
chairs in an out well when we talk about
the positive qualities of them there are
none there are none you keep this
conversation is over you can't just end
a conversation issues all in song